[Music]
this is the collared lizard
the two black bands around their neck
give them their name
coloured lizards can actually run on
their hind legs and reach up to 15 miles
per hour
their tails are used for balancing
themselves when they are up and
sprinting
they are a medium-sized lizard reaching
up to a foot and a half in length
native to western north america they
prefer to live in rocky habitats with
sparse vegetation
today they are widespread but only a few
decades ago their population was
declining clearing land as a form of
fire prevention has greatly helped its
population rebound as they need open
rocky habitats to survive
this is the colored lizard
this is the texas horned lizard a
species which happens to be the official
state reptile and you know what they say
don't mess with texas
[Music]
the texas horned lizard is aptly named
because of its numerous horns the most
prominent horns are the two central ones
located at both the center and rear of
the skull
frequently preyed upon by other animals
its distinct coloration allows it to
camouflage itself amongst vegetation but
when hunted by creatures such as snakes
coyotes and hawks they can either
inflate to a larger size or flatten in
order to blend in with the ground
however their best and more unique
defense against prey is their ability to
shoot a stream of blood from its eyelid
directly into the enemy's eyes
the texas horned lizards population has
dropped dramatically in recent years due
to the state's rapid urbanization
leaving them with a shrinking habitat
this is the texas horned lizard
[Music]
this is the guatemalan beaded lizard
its bite can be deadly but we're a
larger threat to it than it is to us
there are less than 200 of these
creatures left in the wild making it one
of the most endangered lizards in the
world
their beaded black skin is adorned with
yellow spots and bands
they can be found mainly in deserts and
dry forests but even then they're hard
to find as they spend about 70 percent
of their lives underground
measuring up to a foot and a half when
fully grown they can pack a serious
punch
they are one of only two lizard species
that are venomous
the venom is in their saliva and it's
administered when they bite their prey
unfortunately this venom also strikes
fear among humans the biggest threat to
these otherwise docile creatures
hunting habitat loss and poaching have
forced this phantom lizard to fight for
its survival
this is the guatemalan beaded lizard
with the lifespan able to reach as old
as 69 these iguanas can live as long as
humans
this is the grand cayman blue iguana
found only in grand cayman the largest
and westernmost of the cayman islands
their blue skin becomes more prominent
when establishing territory when other
iguanas are nearby
males turn especially bright blue during
breeding season
but their blue skin isn't their only
defining feature they have striking red
eyes and excellent vision which enables
them to notice shapes and movement at
long distances
listed as endangered due to human
activity habitat loss and being preyed
upon by free-roaming predators such as
dogs cats and rats
these beautiful blue lizards face an
uphill battle against extinction this is
the grand cayman blue iguana
[Music]
[Music]
this is the gothica skink
small in size the gothica skink is
covered in camouflaged skin to blend in
with the alpine rocks they call home
the gothicus gink is native to victoria
australia and can only be found in one
area known as the bogong high plains
because they are only found in such a
small area they are vulnerable to
natural disasters such as bushfires
but this isn't the only threat facing
the skinks
their habitat has also been affected by
the construction of ski resorts and the
grazing and trampling from farm animals
but their biggest threat is climate
change
warmer temperatures have allowed new
predators once kept at bay by the cold
into their previously isolated habitat
zoos victoria have been working on a
breeding program to ensure the
preservation of this species and a
rescue and recovery program if there is
an immediate threat to the wild
population
[Music]
this is the gothic skink
[Music]
this is conan and plum
two very still new caledonian geckos
found exclusively in the territory of
new caledonia these geckos can be
spotted on the southern portion of the
island
they have been known to grow up to 14
inches in length
while that may not seem very big conan
and plum are the largest living species
of gecko in the world
typically very calm they only move when
absolutely necessary
a greenish mossy pattern coats their
body camouflaging them in their natural
habitat
their colors range from a rusty red and
brown to green or grey
unlike most geckos it has claws on its
toes and these along with a grasping pad
under the tail help it cling to tree
trunks
the primary threat to this species is
the continued loss and degradation of
forest habitat
this is the new caledonian gecko
[Music]
this is gila
he's a healer monster the only species
of lizard native to the united states
that is venomous
but don't worry these lagged lizards
aren't exactly known for their ability
to give chase
[Music]
native to the southwestern united states
and northwestern mexico the gila monster
is a hard to spot desert dweller
spending 90 of its day underground
squat and heavy set with a large tail
and head they grow to be about 20 inches
long and weigh two pounds their skin is
studded with dorsal scales
black in color with scattered patterns
of orange and red hues they camouflage
well amongst desert pebbles and rocks
healer monsters prey on small desert
animals and their eggs by using their
acute sense of smell
once located they bite into their prey
with their teeth and don't let go they
chew relentlessly until the venom stored
in their salivary glands can work its
way into their prey although quite toxic
their bite is not fatal to adult humans
sadly the number of gila monsters in the
wild are dropping they've lost their
habitat to housing and agricultural
development but since they spend most of
their time underground we do not know
how many are left
this is the gila monster
this is sj a prehensile tailed skink
found in the solomon islands this little
guy is the largest known of its kind
[Music]
the prehensile tailed skink's body is a
greenish olive colour with scattered
black scales
this colouring combined with its slow
movements helps the skink to camouflage
with its surroundings and hide from
enemies
like other skinks its head is flat and
triangular
their strong legs and sharp claws help
them to climb trees
the defining feature on this skink is
its prehensile tail which allows them to
grasp objects and branches for balance
their tail makes up nearly half of their
body's length
the prehensile tailed skink's habitat is
under threat due to deforestation for
lumbar and agriculture
this and the skink's popularity within
the pet trade has threatened their
survival in the wild
this is the prehensile tailed skink
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
centro
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
animals
[Music]